bonjour bonjour monsieur le professeur
d'imitation bonjour monsieur je voudrais
faire un numéro je prenne bureau
d'imitation dans le mien avons demandé
leur mutation faut savoir si vous êtes
doué d'abord a bien sûr lui le temps
dont vous disposez c'est pourquoi pour
avril pour avril soit 82 82 ans on aura
juste le temps est important à faire un
petit test
oui avec sa wii qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me faire avec hoballah président
hugh psyché repos nouveau court
désormais oui où les ouïghours pas mal
votre jean richard hannon tout autre
chose avec ça avec challans l'avis de
tous petits petons valentins et
valentines c'est peut-être un peu trop
mais pas autre chose je pouvais faire un
jour tu verras on sa rencontre
je peux vous faire également
j'aimerais tant voir syracuse
desjardins
dans leurs bras
au pire ça parce que vous allez faire
péter les basses que vous allez vous
casser la voix çà n'est pas très juste
voilà ça c'est très dangereux si je vous
mets était pile comme ça et que moi je
vous dise
et je suppose je suppose en effet pas
que je sois à l'adjudant une terre la
brute de la brigade de saint tropez et
que je vous dis je me cherche le chômage
est allé un peu fort 1 c'était le goût
c'était pas tellement utile ça vous
intéresse rapport par contre de faire
une imitation plus actuelles avec la
voix de monsieur philippe bouvard
par ailleurs que moi l'accent parisien
et ça ne va pas très bien et en plus
c'est c'est plutôt philippe boulevard et
puis physiquement ces lointains qui
purent l accent du midi
si vous pouviez prébois à a échoué vous
prenez un béret comme ça vous le mettez
de travail hier voilà le sourire sud est
comme ça il aimait à l'aventuré à et
vous dites par exemple je sais pas moi
maman moment à regarder mais des
troubles à chinois problème je suis noir
piano et oui pas joué si non alors
j'aime et dont le pire est comme ça
j'aimerais comme ça le sourire le
sourire la chine et aux fidèles ma maman
regarde mais d'un piano 3 blanche
c'est bien beau de vos claviers là
dedans vous savez un que j'aimerais bien
faire alors si vous pouviez me le faire
faire dans cinq six mois gage bourg
tu sais quoi faire sauter rails et je me
débrouille je modère là il a bien voulu
et voilà vous allez me faire voir moi je
vais vous la lune
il est rasé ce matin et oui j'étais
obligé pour les non-initiés pas il faut
pas pour lui il faut pas se raser ses
traits et puis surtout surtout n'est
besoin de ça oui voilà qu'est ce qu'ils
auraient gâcher les oreilles à dégager
ce qu'on l'a surnommée le mic et de la
chanson française
ça tombe bien parce que sa femme à
dessin animé et
c'est peut-être pas à ses ouailles et
regardez là moi je veux mais des
oreilles frais voyez c'est plus proche
de la vérité je vous fait alors la voie
pour sauver du temps mais de type e ces
combats
alors je vais essayer alors moi c'est
difficile vous avez l'habitude je suis
le poinçonneur des lilas l'horloge
arrive ça je sois j'ai peur de grimacer
un peu trop ou n'ont-ils pas un cendrier
s'il vous plaît alors je lui donne les
deux oreilles c'est tout ce que je veux
faire formule excusez moi allez au
revoir monsieur patrick sébastien